Ми сьогодні будемо слухати дев'ять
класичних університетів але так само
звідується весь вся палітра вищих
навчальних закладів які ми виділяємо на
фінансування університетської науки якщо
це Минулого року було
367 млн орієнтовно то цього року це
понад 507 млн тобто кошти зросли десь на
понад 38%, але все ще це дуже мало це
орієнтовно 10% того що взагалі йде на
фінансування науки
що ми ще можемо насправді зробити крім
налочуування коштів це показати приклад
прозорості відбору за відповідними
критеріями коли справді кращі ті хто
пропонують кращі тематики кращі
можливості і здатні їх реалізувати
справді будуть отримувати фінансування
Тому
зараз у Міністерстві освіти і науки ми
працюємо над удосконаленням самого
порядку проведення конкурсу над цими
критеріями і звичайно основна наша ідея
все-таки можливість імплементації
результатів цих досліджень і це по
всьому спектру питань Наприклад ми зараз
проводимо реформування середньої освіти
і очікуємо що ті тематики які йдуть
власне щодо досліджень пегогічних мають
бути орієнтовані на реформу щоб ми могли
їх імплементувати якщо це технічні вищі
навчальні заклади і класичні так само
частина факультетів без сумніву сьогодні
безумовним пріоритетом є
обороноздатність країни тобто для нас
Важливо щоб ці дослідження були
суголосні з пріоритетами які є в
українському суспільстві в українській
економіці
щодо конкурсу 2016 року по якому
звітуються наші науковці у ньому взяли
участь 132 вищнавчальні заклади подали
834 проекти з цих проектів було
підтримано і профінансовано 511 проектів
е приємно відраду що фактично на цей рік
зросло фінансування на науку частини
університетів які зробили силь проекти
сильні
пропозиції навіть на
55% фінансування а в цілому для
більшості університетів які таі
отримали кошти на Наукові дослідження це
зростання становить від 15 до
25%.
тому я звичайно зичу вам успішного звіту
він правда дуже короткий регламент
всього 12 хвилин і неможливо тому
зосередитись на деталях роботи я
закликаю проректорів з наукової роботи
ее намагатися
е
розповісти якомога доступніше про
результати вашої роботи